David what did you think and
tell us also why you chose
the answers that you did.
>> So I said that these five were
all birds, each of them have wings,
each of them have feathers, and
I know that each of them lay eggs.
The other three are kind of interesting.
This is a sugar glider, and
it flies, and we often think of
flying as a bird behavior, but it
doesn't fly the same way birds do, and
it doesn't have the other
features that birds have.
It has fur instead of feathers and
doesn't actually have wings and
we also know it doesn't lay eggs.
A bat is even more interesting.
A bat does have wings, but it doesn't
have feathers the way birds do and
bats actually give birth to live young.
The platypus shown here is
an interesting case because it actually
lays eggs,
it has a bill like a bird does,
and it also has flippers
the way a duck does.
But it's still not a bird because
it doesn't have feathers.
So I would say that these
five are all our birds.
Some of the things that we often
attribute to birds like flying,
the blue bird, and
the eagle, and the duck do.
Penguins and
ostriches don't actually do,
but they're still birds because they
meet our other criteria for birds.
>> That was a good answer,
David, thank you.
Note that David was able to classify
these eight animals into birds, which
one of these animals belong to the class
of birds and which did not belong to it?
Notice also that he used some
criteria to decide on that.
He has some notion it seems
of what is a typical bird,
what kind of features
does a typical bird have.
Here's some notion of what
are the basic conditions that something
must satisfy in order to
be considered a bird.
And if those conditions are not being
satisfied, he would reject them and
say those are not birds.